[Musique]
bonsoir paula slayer merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors comment
réagissent les autorités israéliennes
aux accusations d'human rights watch
lille et lyon ont utilisé les autorités
israéliennes ont rejeté le rapport de
human rights watch
ils ont déclaré qu'il était absurde où
il faut et un gros t'es assis sur les
affaires étrangères israélien a publié
une déclaration disant que miles patch
est connu pour sa position anti
israéliennes lesquelles il veut pour
voir le boycott contre l'état hébreu
dans le même temps le fait que ce
rapport n'est pas été partagée avec les
autorités israéliennes avant la
publication ne lui ont pas permis de
produire des commentaires et cela
montrerait que la valeur de propagande
de ce rapport il son manque de
crédibilité
les autorités israéliennes souhaite
souligner le fait que la minorité
palestinienne
difficile de toute l'étendue des droits
civiques après que le hamas a pris le
pouvoir dans la bande de gaza en
cisjordanie les palestiniens vivent sur
des territoires disputés sujet des
négociations de paix et cela
justifierait les actions prises contre
les palestiniens pour des raisons
sécuritaires en tout premier lieu
dans ce rapport la cemac est très
importante puisque les ong dénoncent des
faits d' apartheid sans comparer avec ce
qui s'est passé pour autant en afrique
du sud
que reprochent les ong à la politique
menée par israël vis-à-vis des arabes
sur son sol et des populations
palestiniennes évoque une intention de
dominer les styles bien il parle de
pression s'é tait
sic d'actes inhumains et tout cela
équivaut à une situation de partage
selon la convention des nations unies
sur l'apartheid
la définition de l'apartheid et
l'intention par un groupe pourtant donné
un autre c'est le cas en israël
il y à un deuil ou systématique par
exemple permis de construire des
relations de raison des restrictions de
en est la liberté les circulations sur
des pc neutre pour toutes ces raisons
qu'il y à un système d'apartheid
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'israël
est visé par de telles accusations
amnesty international dénonce également
depuis longtemps le blocus de gaza
instauré en 2007
thanks to make gilsoul djiby les
critiques tels nationale le blocus sur
la bande de gaza est illégal
j'ai récemment qu'il ya des commentaires
sur le fait qu'israël ne fournit pas de
vaccin 5 million de palestiniens qui
vivent sur la bande de gaza et en
cisjordanie
contrairement à leurs obligations en
vertu du droit international en tant que
puissance occupante les autorités
israéliennes mènerait également des
campagnes de discrimination et
d'intimidation envers des manifestants
pacifiques palestiniens ce ne sont que
certaines accusations lancées contre
israël par des organisations telles que
amnesty international alors preuve
d'ailleurs quelles peuvent être les
conséquences de ce rapport pour israël
alors qu'il ya quelques semaines à peine
la cour pénale internationale a annoncé
à l'ouverture d'une enquête sur
d'éventuels crimes de guerre commis en
cisjordanie et dans la bande de gaza
entre en souscription des conséquences
pourraient être très importantes
peut-être plutôt du côté simple
qui est diplomatique est que dans le
fait vous avez mentionné la caisse
pénale internationale de la haye
ce rapport pourrait aubry consist ait
des éléments de preuve pour la cour
pénale internationale
même si le gouvernement israélien a
déclaré que la cpi n'avait pas
d'autorité était biaisé contre l'état
hébreu
dans certains pays de la communauté
internationale pourrait reconnaître à la
palestine en tant qu'etat suite à ce
rapport ou tout du moins leur fournir
plus d'assistance
cela pourrait également d'autre part à
renforcer les tensions entre les
israéliens et les palestiniens alors que
les négociations de paix n'ont pas
repris depuis presque une décennie doc
lui aura sans doute des retombées
merci beaucoup pour l'asl ailleurs
journaliste pour rt internationale